hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is nexus 5x uh didn't forget about it i
just started testing it after i was done
with nexus 6p and i'm going to make this
one really short and sweet because
essentially this is the same exact
software as nexus 6p but different
hardware so in name and in person the
nexus 5x is actually a successor to the
beloved nexus 5 from two years ago it's
made by lg again too and it keeps a lot
of the stormtrooper panda looks from
that phone and then brings them into the
world of 2015 specs and this is what a
lot of people are looking for in a new
nexus and i like it a lot it keeps those
flat sides for easy grip and soft touch
finish everywhere this time and just
overall a pretty clean design even with
the huge nexus font on the back so when
comparing it to nexus 5 i actually kind
of like the new design a little bit
better
though with the exception of the
slightly bigger camera hump which just
means it'll rock a bit if you try to
text while it's on a table but yeah
overall this phone feels good to me it's
lightweight especially when compared to
some metal phones some have said like it
feels cheap without any metal and i do
tend to agree a bit but i've had no
problems with the actual build it's put
together very well and the smaller
design makes it easier to grip than the
bigger phones especially with that
fingerprint reader which i realize might
have been harder to reach on the back of
the 6p for people with bigger hands now
in this smaller body you got a smaller
display a 5 inch 1080p panel but more
importantly it's an lcd panel now
instead of an ammo led which means
colors are a bit less saturated and
definitely pops less but this isn't
something most people will notice until
i guess you hold it side by side with a
much better screen
and 1080p at this size is still 423 ppi
so it's still plenty sharp the one place
i notice the lcd making a difference is
when ambient display turns on especially
at night when you can see the whole
display light up even though it's
supposed to be black interestingly
though i didn't see this have much of an
effect on battery life and speaking of
battery that's another thing that's
different in this phone so smaller phone
equals smaller battery and the nexus 5x
is rocking a 2700 milliamp hour cell so
it's actually not that small but it's
not 3400 milliamp hours or anything so
it's a decent size for what's inside and
battery life is pretty average i have no
problems getting through a day of what i
consider normal use you know plenty of
twitter email and feedly stuff like that
but i pretty much never made it past a
full day what's nice though is android
6.0 best new feature is doze and i've
noticed this with pretty much every
marshmallow phone i've tested standby
time is excellent actually while i was
testing nexus 6p i had this 5x sit on my
desk for literally a week still signed
in and pulling notifications and
everything and it was fine so if you're
a lighter user and your phone spends
more time in standby mode you'll have no
problem with battery life here and this
is the usb type-c phone also as we
expected with new nexuses and thankfully
there is rapid charging here even faster
in terms of percentage than the 6p since
the battery is smaller so we're talking
something like four hours of use from 10
minutes of being plugged in all right
the other largest difference between
nexus 5x and 6p would just be what's
inside the specs and as a 400 phone
nexus 5x kind of has what you would
expect in an upper mid tier device
snapdragon 808 and 2 gigabytes of ram
and the performance is pretty good with
stock android now naturally there's some
concern that since it's not super high
end there will be some lag or delay but
i really haven't found that and graphics
performance is just pushing 1080p so
it's been just fine smooth all around
the gigabyte less of ram might be more
of an important loss if you're someone
who multitasks a lot but even so apps
open quickly and switching back and
forth between them has been a breeze and
nexus 5x handles heavy stuff like gaming
really well too again at 1080p in fact i
think the only place i saw lag more than
once or twice was the camera app and
this is actually the same with me on the
6p after a while you can double tap the
power button to open it quickly and
sometimes it loaded up nice and quick
and you can take the shot other times it
hesitated big time and actually missed
the shot so this is probably the one app
in marshmallow that i've had any sort of
performance issues with but once you get
in a groove and use this phone with
normal use it's pretty much fine oh and
speaking of the camera this phone is
rocking the exact same optics and sensor
as the nexus 6p so no difference in
image quality there which is great
because that's actually a pretty good
camera the only minor difference is the
processor is capable of pushing 120
frames per second slow motion instead of
240. but if you're interested in image
quality samples i'll have a link below
to that this is a great camera for the
price of the phone and you also have the
fingerprint sensor on the back in the
same place it's a little bit easier to
reach since the phone's a bit smaller
and i'm not sure if it's the same sensor
as the one in the huawei made 6p but it
doesn't really matter because it's also
really good setup was a breeze took less
than 20 seconds probably and this
fingerprint sensor is super quick and
accurate every time i'm glad i have it
set up and that's it past all your
hardware is just stock android 6.0
marshmallow there aren't a whole lot of
surface bells and whistles it's just
pure clean functional experience like
that we used from previous nexuses and i
think that suits this phone really well
nice and clean hardware nice and clean
software overall a very well-rounded
device and a really nice sequel to nexus
5. so overall with nexus 5x it isn't the
best phone at its budget or anything
like that but it is one of the best and
really if you were looking forward to
nexus or if you're a nexus guy if you
wanted a refresh of the nexus 5 then
this is the phone you're looking forward
to so overall that's who i'd recommend
the phone to people who want a nexus
device people who want an unlocked
device people who want that pure stock
android experience and people who want
to be first in line for updates not
second not third must be first so that's
what this device will get you for the
price that's basically it thank you for
watching this review video if you
enjoyed it feel free to hit that thumbs
up button below or even below that
there's a subscribe button if you want
to see more videos like this thanks for
watching and i'll talk to you guys in
the next one
peace